it is the best of vegas las vegas
weekly's latest issue highlights some of
the top businesses shows and
personalities in our city of course
they've profiled imagine dragons before
joining us now brock radke editor at
large hey there brock
hey how you doing good how are you how
are you i know you love sports we're
going to kick it off with sports we all
know that vegas loves to support its
teams it's
athletes and this category i bet is
growing every year so
our readers your readers want to put the
spotlight on some clear-cut champs
apparently
yeah the more sports we get in vegas the
bigger this category gets when we do the
best of vegas issue every year
so some obvious winners uh best male
athlete
is mark andre fleury of course vegas
golden knights
that one uh similarly another no-brainer
best female athlete is asia wilson
las vegas aces just played in the
all-star game in mandalay bay yesterday
she headed to the olympics later this
month so a great choice there
but maybe one surprising pick was uh
best sports book
that's a category that is usually
dominated by
some really kind of institutions of
sports books around town
and this year the brand new one one is
circa's giant sports book
won the best of vegas ward yeah it is
giant i remember when we were there for
the grand opening and we were talking
about how long it was
and then the screen of course and then
you got the stadium swim of course
outside my goodness it beat everything
else
in the state didn't it yeah yeah it's
hard to compete with something that uh
magnificent massive all right our next
topic brock
food the topic everybody loves to talk
about but you say there were some
surprises in the reader's choice
selection for restaurant awards
right food is always gets the most votes
from our readers in the different
categories every year
everybody always wants to talk about
that pizza best pizzeria
again this is one that is usually
dominated by some
favorites that have been in town for a
long time and this year
pizzeria monzu which is a really great
restaurant been around for a few years
on west flamingo won for best pizzeria
kind of similarly best taco shop which
a lot of times roberto's wins that i
think just because they have so many
locations around town and they're so
popular
but this year's best taco shop winner
was abuelas tacos was
a little mom and pop on east sahara all
right
well we look forward to looking at all
the big time
winners thank you so much for your time
brock make sure everybody pick up a copy
of this week's issue
and of course we'll see you next time
doesn't look great there christian
looks amazing and i'm taking notes here
always a good uh
good opportunities to go check out new
places that's right